yippie-ki-yay [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the top 50 Christmas movies
according to the tomato meter
[Music]
it's a tattoo little home alone is in
the 40s bump that up to the top 10 top
20 man home alone you kidding me
it's got to be way out in this this
movie was so successful and made a huge
star out of Macaulay Culkin I'm
surprised that that should be in the top
25 for sure I'm surprised it's down in
the low forties all of the stuff that
home alone is spawned is the reason why
I love it while I was very happy to see
that home alone is on this list at
number 46 and is fresh I was devastated
to see that home alone too lost in New
York one of the great sequels of our
time was not on this list and is in fact
rotten excuse me oh how dare you
terney I am absolutely with you a little
like recorder talk boy thing that he
used was not a real toy before that
movie and it was so popular they started
making him but Kevin still needs to be
slapped in his mouth for calling his mom
a dummy I will never forget that Kevin
McCallister I would have called my mom a
dummy cut to the memorial service me and
the casket the families all around the
movie would have been 15 minutes so
because the Christmas list goes across
multiple years we decided to order it by
the adjusted tomato meter or tomato
meter as you folks thanked it takes into
account the number of reviews for each
movie the year of release of that movie
as well as the average tomato meter
score for the film's released at the
same time as that movie puts it into a
big meaty algorithm and plops out
something that allows you to compare
tomato meter scores across different
films across different decades
what a good time that is a Christmas
movie they do the garbage film sorry
mom-in-law
mom-in-law that's time five for me I
watch that all the time
Clark Griswold just trying to provide
the perfect Christmas holiday who was
family and he's screwing up left and
right I'm sorry I'd like the like the
freakin cousin on whatever he is the one
who's gone psycho now the Quaid yeah the
Quaid
the unsexy Quaid I know Alex also hates
Randy Quaid but but he's actually he's
actually pretty good but I do like as a
Beverly D'Angelo yeah she's fabulous
she's so beautiful what an unsung hero
Oh God
having to be the straight man to Chevie
chase thankless and then the round robin
of Griswold kids it was weird how in the
vacation movies their ages would change
like in one movie the brother would be
older and the next movie the sister
would be older my head Canon is that the
Griswolds are cannibals and they eat
their children and then they get new
ones every vacation this movie
represents Christmas is definitely one
of my favorites
I [ __ ] hate that movie I dropped the
f-bomb Scott hates this movie Love
Actually is not a good movie
I love parts of love actually I hated my
life after I watched it and I wish I
could have that time back
if you don't just love it regardless
because of all the mood it inspires
there's something completely wrong with
you
I felt like I was being spoon-fed
with my nose held shut a romantic comedy
one bite after another without being
allowed to chew God when he is wrong he
is so wrong about stuff you're looking
at Alan Rickman buying a necklace for
not his wife in a store and it's being
wrapped by none other than Rowan
Atkinson would you like it give it round
its Alan Rickman's wife Emma Thompson
listening to Joni Mitchell alone because
that's the present that she got for
Christmas from our husband one of the
best moments in a Christmas movie ever
how do you get more human than those
moments great Drake and anybody else out
there can have their nice little fantasy
about Love Actually and what a great
Christmas film it is it's got maybe the
worst fat shaming bit I've ever seen the
end of the movie dude shows up I want to
marry your daughter the guy's overjoyed
and then they cut to the chubby daughter
and she's thinking oh my god I just won
the lottery
and then everybody universally agrees no
not her
no she's gonna die alone I'll talk about
the hot one it shows stalker ISM it
shows unrequited love
it shows abusive love it's what love
isn't actually it's shallow I've
actually had relationships and because I
said that I hated Love Actually that's
how beloved this film is like you know
what embrace your taste you know that's
why they make chocolate vanilla
[Music]
that's the Christmas Carol set to Bill
Murray it gets no better than that
Bill Murray you kidding me he's a
national treasure if anyone says that
they don't like that movie can you call
me immediately so I can come over here
and beat their ass Christmas Carol at 24
and Scrooge 239 is absolutely ridiculous
Scrooged way better realistic aspect of
what Christmas is so he's visited by the
traditional three ghosts except that one
of them is Carol Kane she's wearing
fairy wings like yes just all kinds of
yes that's some good Murray like I had
there's just so many good periods of
Murray Bill Murray and probably what I
think is one of his best roles I know
they're gonna say like Caddyshack and
other things but I think he's amazing as
Frank Cross it's got moments that are
hilarious it's got moments that are
actually kind of heartfelt I sob like a
newborn baby when I watch that because
it reminds me that you can always change
you can always turn your life around you
can always have remorse for something
and you can always surrender to all the
beauty that surrounds us in this world
[Music]
the ref is awesome the ref is a sharp
acerbic funny Christmas movie dark
really worth seeing Denis Leary
just at the height of his powers it's
got a younger Kevin Spacey in it what I
mean - just forget every movie I mean I
don't know what to do it's a
dysfunctional family at Christmas where
they argue and yell and like the kid has
like secrets and doesn't want to come
home and he's off at military school
it's amazing why is the rep higher on
this list than screwed it does anybody
gather the family around the hearth and
the fire okay kids come on over bring
your friends it's Christmas Eve time to
watch the ref I'm all about the real
Christmas or grandma you know confesses
how she never loved grandpa across from
the cranberry sauce that's real
Christmas
[Music]
it's like Santa played by Billy Bob
Thornton in a dressing room with Lauren
Graham from the Gilmore Girls and they
are just doing it and it is nasty and
that's Christmas to me Marcus get this
kid off before he pisses on me all right
Billy Bob Thornton yeah just whatever
what a Lech not a huge fan of Bad Santa
I'm gonna let you kids in on a little
secret it's a fine movie it's funny but
it's just so crude and so crass and you
need a movie like that on Christmas the
dark and the light because the holiday
season it is of many things to many
people it can be it can be depressing it
can be nerve-racking it can be
frustrating when I see a Christmas film
I want to be uplifted I want to believe
in something I want to share in the
spirit of my fellow person and all the
hope that we can be something better
than we are
the rest of the year or I want to see a
German terrorist dropped out of a window
either one is fine with me for Christmas
[Music]
I completely love Batman Returns and I
think that movie stands out for a number
of reasons
penguin soldiers being primary among
them Danny DeVito is a scary little
bugger as that penguin he's real good
and then you got some Christopher Walken
in there you got Billy Dee Williams in
there definitely for Michelle Pfeiffer's
Catwoman or Selina Kyle just I think the
most iconic Batman villain no no no no I
can't say that equally iconic with Heath
and the Joker but that was such an
incredible performance this scene where
she transforms into Catwoman her
performance is just tour de force just
out of control I always have fond
memories of Michelle I'm gonna say that
I think he'll and I have different views
of why we love Michelle as Catwoman I
think well he might have been that's a
sexy Catwoman I was like that's a really
well styled Catwoman she is just fierce
just like Oh Michelle Pfeiffer oh damn
five dog whoa all about that fight life
just watch that movie make more fight it
up I love grandmas I mean gremlins like
you know did well made like a hundred
and seventy five million in 1984 this is
a film that along with Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom was responsible for
the creation of the pg-13 rating because
it was violent film stars Zach Galligan
a Phoebe Cates takes place in a very
small town the same setting by the way
that was used for hill valley and back
to the future there's a there's a
beautiful very sad scene in the middle
of the film when Phoebe Cates is
recalling the story about how her father
died trying to come down the chimney
dressed as Santa Claus the worst
Christmas story anyone has ever heard on
earth he was slowly decaying in the
chimney
and now back to your regularly scheduled
Christmas romp gremlins number 23 that's
probably a good spot gremlins ruined my
childhood like two weeks came out yes
please take me to go see gremlins it
scared the crap out of me oh I couldn't
sleep I can't talk about gremlins
without plugging the fact that I'm in
the key and peele gremlins too scared
you'll see me I make a suggestion
we're going around and pitching
different gremlins I pitched the
googly-eyed gremlin that is a top ten
Christmas movie if there ever was one
another overrated movie even though I'm
a big fan of Will Ferrell elf just
didn't cut the mustard for me and what
does cut the mustard even me you disgust
me
how can you live with yourself oh you're
dead inside if you don't like elf why
would you have a problem with elf
staring for real I think it's just one
of those things where people really
connect with the joy of that character
buddy he's so beautiful and innocent and
enthusiastic and excited he's kind of
like a kid on Christmas morning which is
I think the feeling people want when
they want to return to something around
Christmastime and just the scene where
wolf arrow is singing to him singing to
his father it's such a mismatch but it
works so well because the chemistry
between them is infectious because they
they don't belong together but they do
because they really are literally and
figuratively family and that's what
Christmas is all about I love you
this is Eddie Murphy dan Aykroyd and
Jamie Lee Curtis at the height of their
powers not just Eddie Murphy Eddie
Murphy and Jonathan Landis in the 1980s
forces of nature and training places is
so damn funny
yeah Trading Places was just edgy I
remember they were just having a pardon
you know he was just dancing they'll be
busting in the room people just naked in
there that that's the holidays to me
what we really get in training places
it's the first time did we see Eddie
Murphy outside of SNL still being just
as funny as he was on that show Eddie
Murphy was the fig legs and
lifted him up and he was like oh I got
he's so funny but there's a sweetness to
it there is a little tinge of sadness he
is able to convey so much at such a
young age in Trading Places
it's an amazing piece of work love this
movie love love love this movie it's
rated R as gritty I feel like movies
were grittier in the eighties it does
have one bad moment
dan Aykroyd does wear blackface I think
the only reason why this one wouldn't be
higher on the list is because probably
not enough people have seen it and the
reason why I say that is because it it's
from this Japanese animation director
named Satoshi Kon who did a bunch of
really mind-bending sci-fi style movies
I think people have is here because it's
an anime and the title Tokyo Godfather
sounds like a crime drama but this one
is more of like a a heartfelt really
genuine kind of a family story it does
have some dark elements to it but the
story of it is generally that these
three homeless people discover an
abandoned baby on Christmas Eve and
their whole mission throughout the night
is to return that baby to its its mother
one of the other reasons why I
specifically have a connection to this
movie is that the baby that they find
and one other character that I won't
spoil in the movie is named Kyoko and
that's my grandmother's name also so
yeah
we're exports is essentially a horror
film that kind of takes the Santa and
elves myth and turns it into this thing
where Santa is actually a demon and all
of the elves are like these old looking
guys who come to people's homes to
snatch children and take them to Santa
in order to feed him Christmas is about
heart and family and the experience your
memories traditions how does any
tradition around a movie that no one's
ever seen I think it's from Finland it's
done really well the imagery towards the
end is really fantastic the character
design is great I think it's even got
some moments that are genuinely
frightening and the ending is just
bonkers so I think it's a really fun
watch and kind of a nice bit of
counter-programming during the Christmas
season this is a fallacy it can't be one
of the best Christmas movies if it's not
a movie that we're all like no one's
ever said that about rare influence my
favorite Christmas movie is a Charlie
Brown Christmas number 15 on the list
that feels like criminally low for that
movie that has been on television every
year since 1965 when it first aired and
everyone loves it I'm a big peanuts fan
I love Charlie Brown and the gang Snoopy
is my guy man I love how Snoopy just
does his own thing he's a dog with his
life he's chilling his house is lavish
have you ever seen the inside of
Snoopy's doghouse
I think the key scene and the special is
when Linus he takes a spotlight and he
quotes this Bible verse and as the years
go on I find that that scene has become
more and more powerful at I think as the
world becomes less and less religious
and I'm not a literate person at all I
find it very moving it's hard for me to
think of 14 movies Christmas movies that
are better than a Charlie Brown
Christmas and you know it's not even my
number one
so that's kind of crazy it was a Lucy
out there gave them special rotten
bastard so what a lovely fairy tale what
a sad maudlin fairy tale that period of
Tim Burton with Edward Scissorhands
Beetlejuice pee-wee's big adventure just
creating these worlds with his own logic
and rules but you are immersed and it
makes complete and total sense even
though it's fantastical and wild then
eventually he made Planet of the Apes I
didn't know that was a Christmas movie
like we went through several different
seasons with this this guy in this
family like Christmas I mean it showed
up but it wasn't like the theme of it
like you know I we throwing movies in
here where Christmas is mentioned if
that's the case leave the weapons should
be on here cuz I remember the scene and
leave the weapon there was some
Christmas decorations in the background
why is it leave the weapon on here
come on weak the way it's a Christmas
movie there's a lot of action there's a
lot of buddy but it takes place around
Christmas if a movie takes place around
Christmas you're gonna tell me Edward
Scissorhands is more of a Christmas
movie then Lethal Weapon I would say
Edward Scissorhands is not a Christmas
movie I mean it has parts of it that are
in Christmas but it also has parts of
it's like dead summer and then they go
to like talk shows I would say very much
less of that movie is about Christmas
it's just the ice sculptures
[Music]
that is the seminal Christmas movie it's
fun it's got the spirit it talks to our
childhood it talks to adulthood it gives
us so much that we can relate to a
Christmas story is one of the best
Christmas movies of all time you shoot
your eye out yo I didn't see this movie
in its entirety until 2000 I just now
saw Christmas Story is literally like
all that Christmas is right now which is
the capitalist materialistic focus of
children and convincing them that it's
Santa Claus
that's really all Christmas is right now
I get it the kid wants a BB gun is there
anything else I need to know about that
movie
[Music]
the Christmas which I believe is by
admin animation who have a team behind
chicken run wallace and gromit etc and
it's really just a really fantastic
animated Christmas film that I think is
going to be a classic in 10 or so years
I'm not sure why Arthur Christmas is
number 12 it's a fine movie Santa's got
a kid and the kids got to save the day
it's adorable
I saw the movie liked it immediately
forgot about it and you're telling me
Arthur Christmas is better than Scrooged
it's better than home alone is better
than Black Christmas unlike a lot of
animated films are very popular these
days it doesn't rely just on pop-culture
references etc it's got a beautiful
amount of hot vine movie should not be
looking diehard right in the face on any
list of Christmas movies this debate
that has been going on for more than 30
years is die hard a Christmas movie
who cares what are we getting so worked
up about it takes place at Christmas
it's an unconventional Christmas film
there I ended the debate for you die
hard is definitely a Christmas movie and
I'm super glad that it's on the list I
know it's a Christmas movie because it
plays Run DMC's a Christmas in Hollis
Queens which is the best Christmas song
ever
it's a holiday staple man wholesome good
times so the clean foul language the
bullet holes the explosion the bloody
bare feet was more Christmas than that
I do not agree with the ranking at all
it's at number 11 it definitely deserves
to be in the top 10 nay the top 5 I
would put diehard at number 2 on my own
personal best Christmas movie list Ted
too low I think you should be noble I
mean come on Christmas is not the star
of the show here let's get that straight
Christmas is a co-star the star of the
show is yippee-ki-yay [ __ ]
[Music]
the reason mind that movie's awesome is
the music everybody knows that's the
best part of it it's cool animations
cute Boris Karloff's voice is pretty
amazing but it's music it's not one
scene it's all of the music without
question on my personal list the
apartment which is number eight should
be number one the apartment which stars
Jack Lemmon and Shirley MacLaine won
Best Picture in 1960 the apartment is it
a Christmas movie it's a movie that
takes place at Christmas isn't that
diehard region but it's not necessarily
a Santa Claus jingle-jingle movie it's a
movie about men that cheated on their
wives in an apartment this is not
screaming home for the holidays it's one
my favorite movies it's one of your
favorite movies general yeah I think
it's on Chris Jacqueline's top 5 and
also online I love that movie I think
it's a great holiday film even though
it's kind of sad and twisted it kind of
builds to this really emotional sweet
crescendo which I kind of so see those
feelings with Christmas I saw it in the
theatres cinemas we would say back home
in 1993 to whatever it was as a kid and
just fell in love instantly I bought the
soundtrack when it came out and I wore
the crap out of that CD learning every
single song word for word including like
the Oogie Boogie one and all the weird
ones with the three kids kidnapping the
Santa Claus I just incredibly loved that
film The Nightmare Before Christmas
you're more of a how we movie in
my opinion you know as more of a
Halloween vibe even though the title is
the Nightmare Before Christmas I feel
like it's October it's also a Christmas
movie - the music in this movie is great
the look of the film is great it is a
timeless classic that you could play on
Halloween and of course you could also
play it on Christmas it has a lot of
humor it has a big heart it is such a
feel-good movie and it is a movie that I
make a yearly ritual to watch twice
[Music]
I think it's [ __ ] I don't like it I
don't I don't like I don't like the way
the movie opens I don't like that song
meet me in st. Louie I I guess I'm a
horrible person
for not liking a Judy Garland movie
she's a treasure I get it
why is everything old have to be better
I don't like how the top six it's all
just mad old no disrespect to my mom I
will take the number to film on this
list meet me in st. Louis and put it up
against National Lampoon's Christmas
vacation
any day It's a Wonderful Life is the
Citizen Kane of Christmas movies and
like Citizen Kane it needs to be at the
top of that list
I'll tell you right now it should be
number one look at the message of its
Wonderful Life don't kill yourself
that's a pretty great message the world
will miss you you are important you are
needed it's beautiful it's Jimmy Stewart
it's like how could you not love this
movie I'm be honest with you I haven't
watched it's a Wonderful Life since the
80s I know it's on every year five times
a day in the month of December but it's
black and white kind of snobby man black
and white it takes me too long to get
into a black and white movie because
it's black and white I get sleepy
immediately it's just kind of a
feel-good movie and it's been around for
decades that's a classic I don't think
there is anyone who would argue against
that being the top Christmas moving a
Christmas story is better me personally
no it should be number one it's number
one everybody just settled down we got
enough hate mail as it is so it's one
whole life being number one is perfect
and I think the tomato meter speaks the
truth again before there was Tom Hanks
there was a fine young man
banana named Jeff Stewart who set out to
save America it is probably the best
performance James Stewart ever gave on
camera it really shows his range when he
is sitting at the bar after he's lost
the money for the bank and is going to
lose everything else and he's sitting
there praying for God please give me
strength show me the way
it's a wonderful life is more of the
fantasy version of what Christmas used
to be maybe it's about family and being
together and angels and all that very
few people think about that now
to everyone who thinks maybe another
film should be number one I say this go
back and watch it again and you will see
how great this movie truly is it's not
just one of the best Christmas movies of
all time it is one of the best movies of
all time period what's your favorite big
give us your top five what shouldn't be
on here what should be on it was too
high was too low we want to dig deep
with you and see where you stand
wait a minute wait a minute that's an
idea what do you think
[Music]